we're here on CL island off the coast of
Maine to observe the heroic trek of one
baby puffin to the sea in order to do
that we'll have to use special infrared
video because the trek will begin at
night just because this young puffin is
making its trek alone that doesn't mean
it has neglectful parents far from it
puffins parents come to this colony in
the spring and summer to breed and nest
during the nesting season the puffins
bill takes on vivid colors of red blue
gray and ivory they use these bills for
what's called gaping threatening each
other with harm without actually
fighting they also use them for what's
called building a show of affection
puffins lay one egg per year which is
incubated in turn by each adult for 39
to 43 days when the egg hatches the
parents gather food and bring it back
for the baby for another 45 days
[Music]
only after all that TLC does the baby
feel prepare to trust it's instinct to
make its way to the ocean it's hard to
believe this bird will soon be able to
fly at speeds up to 55 miles an hour
with wings beating over 400 times a
minute
[Music]
once our brave young puffin hits the
water it'll stay at sea for two to three
years protecting itself from natural
hazards like storms and predators and
man-made hazards like oil spills and
nets of fishing trawlers even though our
young puffin has to walk through rocky
crags and craggy rocks
it has instinctively found its new home
in the Atlantic Ocean
in a couple of years it may be back here
ready to mate and of course to be
admired by thousands of tourists who
adore in this odd-looking but lovable
seabird